[Music]
my name's kim van Devere
I'm a professor in the ocean engineering
department and chairman of the MIT
faculty for a few more few more days
anyway I'm standing in for Louie Cabot
as the moderator of this afternoon's
technology day panel on ocean recreation
and sports there we go did you all hear
that
I hope testing ok we're back on it I
won't repeat it all I my name is kim van
Devere I'll be the moderator this
afternoon our four guests are professor
Jerry Milgram from the ocean engineering
department Ted Van Deusen who owns his
own a company and is going to talk to
you about his exploits among other
things in making racing shells Don Liu
from American Bureau of shipping and
Peter Quigley who's I saw in the
building seven Lobby a mast and and sail
from sail board with carbon fiber
components from fiber spar Peter's
company all five of us are graduates of
one degree or another of the ocean
engineering department and I'm not going
to I'm not one I don't know one of these
people who gives lengthy introductions
and I since I know roughly what each of
the speakers are going to talk about
today I think I'm going to let them
speak for themselves as to the kind of
things that they do and are interested
in we're going to follow what the order
in the program which is Professor
Milgram and then Peter Ted and Don
following the format that I'd like to
use this afternoon as each one has a
presentation of 15 minutes or so that
they would make and if you have a
willing I'll entertain a couple of
questions after each presentation if you
have something specific you'd really
like to address to them right then and
at the end
of the fourth presentation last
presentation we'll open it up to a more
general audience participation
discussion and you can ask questions of
any of the speakers so with that
Jerry start please from this morning
session you can tell that what we did it
American cubed was a different approach
to making fast sailboats so that's the
kind of ocean engineering which I'm
going to describe here this different
approach and Kim's volunteered to put on
the view graphs for me so we'll just
start what I show you here is how is is
a flowchart of how one traditionally
designs a sailing boat in this day and
age there is very little science in it
there's a there's there's some
experience and if you start with the
fast design and you need to change to a
new design and can modify your fast
design you got a chance of doing
something that's fast
maybe you've all seen the fact that the
difficulties of this approach some
designer will come out with a bunch of
fast boats and four years later he'll be
an also-ran
and that's because he stuck with this he
can't expand so this is how it's
normally done and we didn't do that Kim
you're gonna have that you're gonna it's
pretty much they pretty pretty quick
we're gonna go through and pretty quick
that week we concluded in America cube
that that was not a good approach
because what I show you here as a
function of wind speed is the difference
in time it takes to sail around the
course both for the windward legs and
for the entire course when you change
the resistance of the boat by 1% and so
it's it's a huge effect so in 10 knots
of breeze if you're if you're if you've
got 1% more resistance you've lost the
race by 33 seconds so you've got to do
better than messing around which is what
the traditional yacht designer does the
the the late van Clark used to call
those people goddamn boat drawers
and those of you who know van will
appreciate the comment or who knew him
the approach we took it America cute
they got on the next view graph and this
is the flowchart of what we did and the
items that have orange inside the boxes
are ones where there's lots of science
and there's two big design tasks or
three design tasks and the flow goes
both way to those because the science
has to feedback to the designs in order
to come up with something that's very
fast you'll see at the centerpiece of
this technical approach are our velocity
prediction programs they're the key
because they allow us before you build a
boat to evaluate how fast they're going
to be and just very briefly going
through this you'll see you have to do
some you might call this preliminary
design if any of your big ship naval
architects then you know something about
the way you can design some holes your
tank test them you got it you've got to
somehow get sail forces you've got to
somehow design good sails you've got to
include the added resistance due to sea
waves and eventually you get down to
design selections some testing there's
some feedback loops here that aren't
shown and eventually you get to what you
want if you do it right okay we have the
next one this velocity prediction
program which is the just lost something
which is the center which is the center
piece of the thing can be viewed as a
computer-based balance between
hydrodynamic forces and aerodynamic
forces and the computer will change the
variables that affect the performance of
the boat or that measure the performance
of this boat to speed the gill angle in
the leeway angle until these come into
balance and that's where you're sailing
so this isn't for dynamics this is for
steady-state sailing and it's it's
simply a computer program and the actual
computational parts pretty simple the
hard part are how you model the various
forces that have to go into the model
the next view graphs of block diagram of
one of these velocity prediction
programs which is is
they're to emphasize which is there to
emphasize it emphasized what a small
part of the whole thing the actual
solving of the equations of motion are
the hard part are making the models
making these models which determine the
forces that affect the speed and we're
trying to get to a point where we can
use technology for evaluating potential
designs with resistance differences of
something less than 1% this is a bigger
version of one of the view graphs Bill
Koch showed this morning what we did in
our work is we decomposed the resistance
of the hull into various components now
I need to explain to you that if you
could test full-size boats you wouldn't
need to do this if you had a full-size
boat you tested it has a certain
resistance but you can't test full-size
boats you can you can test models or you
can make approximation resistance
computationally scale differently or
each of them has a different kind of
error and as a result the decomposition
into these various components is useful
this is the the skin friction of the
hall this is the wave making resistance
of the hull skin friction on the
appendages the drag due to due to the
fact that the boat heals and makes a
side force to balance a side force of
the sails and the resistance due to the
sea waves now to how big or each of
those components the next two view
graphs will show you them for for
sailing to windward what I show here is
the fraction of the total resistance
that each of these components makes up
now Kim if you could put on the next one
and then do an overlay of the two
there's two missing here there's the two
that are missing the resistance due to
heel inside force and the added
resistance now if we can do an overlay
and let him struggle with it there we
are you will notice that a typical
windward sailing speeds for these boats
nine and a half knots or so all the
components except skin friction have the
same order of magnitude and skin
friction is bigger and and they're all
all these are around 15% or so and this
is around 40% and I asked you to bear
that in mind that
component of resistances and in in the
conditions you care about the most are
about 15% of the total resistance and
the job that one has to do for potential
designs is to evaluate each of those
components and see how it affects speed
what the VPP does for you is is it will
tell you the speed if you know how big
each one of these components and the
sale forces are there's been a lot of
work done on computational hydrodynamics
for residuary resistance and the people
who do it pride themselves and how good
they are they say look I got it right
within 10 percent well 15 percent of 10
percent 15 percent of the resistance 10
percent errors one and a half percent
it's a minute around the course forget
it good those people have are focused on
their computations and not on the job of
winning a boat race and that's got to be
realized and we realized that and we
realized we had to go to the towing tank
I've got three quick slides we can see
them for you shut that off here and if
we're lucky hmm maybe we have three
quick slides this worked well I guess
we're not gonna see them hmm where's the
man we got him up if there are no slides
okay there you go we have them in view
grid they're just not as good one figure
I forget the slides there and they go in
[Music]
here we go everyone I'd like you to show
that one first well you have to fuss
around a second and that one third
that's that's a view graph of what goes
on at a towing tank and there's a couple
things to see here that are important
technologically by the way I think this
guy's in the audience here the the
models are big scale error in tank
testing is
a big problem if you don't make big
models typically bigger than 20 feet or
so you're not going to get the
resistance measured to less than a
percent accuracies of at least a percent
the models have to be big all of you
some of you are interested in sailboats
and you all know about tank Fiasco's
they're the the businesses is loaded
with stories of them you'll see there
are a lot of models we tested about 40
models we did 99 sets of tank tests each
test was 105 runs 105 runs count back
and forth and the tank were not for 99
sets of tests because we didn't retest
in different appendages was 1,500 miles
in the tank which is about as far as all
our big full-scale boats sailed so we
went about as part in real distance in
model scales we did full-scale so this
shows you some of the instrumentation on
the deck of the model you have to do
this tank testing right it's a whole
bunch of load cells in here and what
habits was a heeled models you can see
it it's a very intensive process and
people and and and it's a process in
where if you want to play this game it
behooves you to do it right now I have a
picture of one of a boat coming down the
tank there we go there's the boat coming
down the tank in the towing tank and if
you do that right you can get the
residuary resistance righty you can get
the best estimate of frictional
resistances that you're going to get
it's not perfect but it's as good as
you're going to do what about the other
components of resistance I before
resistance due to appendages and that's
one thing we're computational
hydrodynamics can help you along here's
here's a view of a keel fin in a bowl
these boats are Bowl killers and these
aspects of that fin in bulb are things
that you can evaluate with computational
fluid mechanics and look at their
results in your velocity prediction
program to evaluate how fast your boats
going to go the next view graph gives an
example of fiddling with the taper ratio
the width of a keel fin at the top to
the width of the bottom and you find
that this this is a measure of drag it's
Britten's kind of long versus taper
ratio you can see that you can gain
about a percent and a half in keel fin
drag yeah about a percent to say two
percent 15 percent of two percent
seventh of a percent about eight seconds
so if you change the taper ratio from
this much - this much another here's
this is the keel fin it's almost
straight up and down and this one's much
smaller at the bottom than at the top if
you do that in gain eight seconds well
it doesn't sound like much but if you
work at these things for a couple years
and gain that eight seconds ten times
you're a winner so that you can do
computationally but computation won't do
the whole job for appendages you've got
to do Windtunnel testing and I show you
a picture of an inferior Windtunnel
tests that's upside down because the way
that most the Windtunnel tests are done
is you mount the body and the floor of
the Windtunnel here's the keel fin
here's the bulb here's some winglets
here's some apparatus to measure to the
flow why do I say that's inferior this
was done by the partnership for
America's Cup technologies who's got
some scientists that didn't come to MIT
working for them and and and the and and
and they did these tests now on the next
view graph I have a just a sketch of how
you do it right and I'll explain to you
why there's a difference I'll turn it
over this model has a hull on the
Windtunnel floor and it has a rudder and
the reason that you need this is the
flow up here is influenced by the
curvature of the hall and you're going
to get the winglet angle wrong for sure
if you don't put the hole there
guaranteed in fact we experiment and we
know you do also when you change the
lift on the keel fin the trailing
vorticity affects the rudder so you got
to do it all you've got to put the
important stuff in now this doesn't have
everything this doesn't have waves
because wind tunnels don't have way so
that isn't there but within their
restrictions that you have you've got to
do everything you can to get as far as
you can to get as far as you can so what
I've given you now is a brief vignette
of how we get the van
hull forces that go into the velocity
prediction program what about the other
half what about the sail forces and this
is a view graph of our measured speed
made good to windward that we actually
measured with one of our boats and the
dotted line was when we did this the
predicted speed and that turns out not
to be good enough in other words you
cannot evaluate one design from another
if you have these kinds of errors in
your speed predictions in particular
this the prediction completely fails to
capture the phenomenon of when the wind
gets below a certain level the speed
suddenly drops we call that falling off
the cliff and depending on the design of
your boat you can move this around you
can move this down here but then this is
going to drop down got to do some
trade-offs so we looked into why we had
the why we had those problems and what
we did is we built the sailing
dynamometer we refurbished one that we
had and this you saw from Bill this
morning in order to in order to get the
sail forces better can we take a look at
this that's a photograph of this sailing
dynamometer it looks like a sailboat on
the outside but inside it's really very
different and it has this frame you can
skip the next view graph the one you had
on because everybody seen it this
morning and we'll go to the one after
that it has it's built with an internal
frame where all the sail forces are
resolved that's the one everything
that's red here is hooked to the rig
everything that's black is hooked to the
boat including the people inside and
that means that if a person touches
something red this thing is going to get
the wrong readings because the load
cells that connect the red stuff to the
hull our computer interface within the
boat you can measure forces on sails and
you can develop a mathematical model for
sail forces with a device like this
which was a scale model of an America's
Cup rig sailed in waves and we tried to
find the best the best approximation we
could to scaled way so we sail
someone protected waters and we
developed a sail model for our velocity
prediction program and what I have next
is the comparison between measurement
and prediction after we got the got the
sail model right okay now so now we had
a way where if we tank tested a boat and
if we design some sails we had a way of
evaluating how fast it was going to go
and and with that one could progress
towards design and remember early on I
indicated that there's feedback between
the science and the design process and
the next view graph is more or less as a
flow chart showing the kind of design
process that we do now once we got to
the point where we knew we could predict
speed if we had time tests we designed a
group of models with systematic
parametric variations no shots in the
dark each one was a systematic variation
from the next one we tested it we
analyzed the its data we learn the best
parameters for San Diego about that time
was the world championship racing before
the America's Cup we learned a lot
because the that the technology couldn't
tell us all particularly about some
aspects of the added resistance due to
sea waves and one of our designers we
had a 10 met 10 person design team and
one of the designers was very good at
recognizing the boats did best in waves
and why and that was very important that
got dialed in he designed the second set
of models tank tested those analyze the
results and figured out what is it that
makes fast boats you see this was the
feedback and that allowed us to design
their final boats and they were very
fast finally last view graph you if
you'll remember this morning Bill Koch
told you that just before the America
cube sailing the America's Cup we
changed appendages and we knew the
appendages that we had were not optimal
however we learned enough with our
velocity prediction programs to use them
to predict speeds for appendages that we
never tested and we knew what we knew we
needed better performance and light wind
and we could sacrifice them
performance in heavy wind so we designed
these new appendages we built them and
change the appendages before the
America's Cup with complete confidence
that these new appendages were going to
work and they did and and they did
exactly what our predictions were what
you saw this morning from from Bill's
talk hat was the actual measurements of
speed differentials and these were the
predictions we predicted it with the new
appendages in a seven knot breeze we
gained about a minute around the course
in an 18 knot breeze we lose a tenth of
a minute and that was that was very very
close to what we actually observed so we
were able by using good engineering
skills and some decent computer
programming to develop predictive tools
that could that could be effective in
the real world situation we'll leave it
at that and listen to the next guy
[Applause]
we can entertain and then remember later
on we'll go we'll have a more open
format after everyone's finished
absolutely probably miss you can't do it
no I understand well in our case with
rules the we were not permitted to use
certain additives they we looked into
potential uses of shapes that would
encourage laminar flow and this was one
of our studies I mean I didn't have time
to tell you everything and we found that
it would be rather ineffective in sea
water because micro but microscopic
bubbles and particulates were enough
triggers for turbulence that if you are
operating above the critical critical
Reynolds number no matter what you did
it was going to become turbulent you
could make it laminar in your test tank
that didn't have the particulates but
you couldn't at sea and for that reason
we did not we did not go to laminar flow
sections sure yes if you guys you said
if you could heat the heat the boat I
mean but that that would do something I
don't think that would be permitted
under this rule but perhaps under some
other
it's going to be in San Diego and the
changes will be incremental because
enough of what our boats looked like has
now gotten around plus 2/3 of our
designers jump ship and went to work for
the foreigners and but they all came
from the west coast and and so so
between what they know very well and
what other people could tell by looking
I think there will be only incremental
changes oh the sail fabric what we'll
have to find talk about that later I
think there's probably some people in
the audience who know that better than I
do
Jerry is that are the two the two
existing boats will they be competitive
in ninety five in your opinion well one
of them one of them couldn't be one of
the boats Cannes is a very big boat it
was it was build in case in case the
wind was much stronger than anticipated
but American Cube would be either
competitive or very close to competitive
I can design a much faster boat right
now whether the other guys are likely to
come up with something that's fast or
two so I would say competitive but not a
winner one last question
lady out here
or a resident who's been in the country
for for a minimum time of two years
prior to the start of the first race
okay that was May the fourth hate the
four all right I think we'll move on to
our next speaker Peter Quigley and we'll
follow the same format a couple of
questions after he finishes and but
there'll be plenty of time at the end
for lots more questions okay they're
good there's a pointer if you want it
people have to know they were with me of
it I'm coming down with a bit of a cold
so if I doze off in the middle of my
talk you'll definitely have a reason to
doze off yourself so what I'd like to
describe I'm I graduated with a
bachelor's degree from the ocean
engineering department 1985 I was some
the recipient of a very wonderful
academic prize called the robert bruce
wallace prize that I received in 85 that
paid for a full year of graduate study
here at the Institute so I think I but
the one distinction that I bring to this
panel is I think I'm the only drop out
from MIT on the panel because the one
year of graduate study that I undertook
here at MIT really was what the long
quote was what the what really fostered
the launch of a company which initially
had to start in a very narrow
application of windsurfing which many of
you have seen if you spend time on the
water near the water all of us have seen
wind surfers but what was interesting
from my perspective is that there was an
emerging type of material which I felt
had much broader application and I began
to become exposed to those materials
while an undergraduate and a graduate
student here so what I want what I'm
gonna do is describe a recreational
sporting goods application that's marine
based but I'm also going to reflect a
little bit on the potential bridge from
that sporting goods application to other
applications in both industrial and
commercial markets and in many ways a
lot of the technology associated with
the America's Cup ultimately can find
its way into a more diverse applications
than simply winning a boat race so I'm
going to reflect a little bit on a very
narrow application of wind surfing but
also reflect on how that might be
applied in a broader sense to emerging
industrial commercial applications so
I'm going to start really just with a
bit of background about what actually I
became interested in I'm not going to
read through this here but what I want
to describe is a type of material which
many of you have been exposed to but
others really are still somewhat not
exposed to and the general class of
material refers to a composite material
and what a composite is we're sitting in
a room that's steel reinforced concrete
where you have very brittle and weak
steel concrete reinforced by steel
members which are
very high strength composites have been
around a long time reinforced straw
brick is an example where the brick was
very brittle going back to prehistoric
times people found if you added straw to
the brick you made a structural element
which had a great deal higher mechanical
properties what so what a composite
material is there's been a lot of
innovation all of us have been exposed
to fiberglass really for 40 or 50 years
in terms of recreational boats
fiberglass is the dominant material
these days and in both motor boats and
recreational sailing boats and that's a
form of composite material glass fiber
reinforcing the polymer material where
are these where are these materials
being used because each of us in this
room probably whether we recognize it or
not has probably been exposed to
composite materials the most where these
materials are most uses in the aerospace
industry applications the b-2 stealth
bomber that has all kinds of complex
radar evading capabilities and as
extreme lightweight the next area where
people have seen these the most is in
Sporting Goods and there isn't anyone in
this room who's played tennis in the
last five years that can find a tennis
racket that's not made out of composite
materials I know Jerry what was the
structural weight in America's Cup in
terms of how much of the structural
weight was composite material
okay so there's another good example the
America's Cup boats in fact in fact the
sails the spars the hulls some of the
appendages were made of composite
materials golfers in the audience know
that graphite and carbon fiber is
becoming much more prevalent in the use
of golf shafts as well as the heads of
the clubs as well so in the first two
applications that makes up about 95
percent of where composite materials are
used but they're beginning to show up
more and more in other applications
people that rap on the fender of a car
will notice it doesn't quite sound like
metal anymore many applications and cars
are using plastics or reinforced
plastics so just to to kind of reference
what I perceived is an opportunity
really going back 10 years now was if
you look at this bottom pie chart it's
probably difficult to see in the back of
the room
the chart on the Left projects what the
potential growth of the use of these
materials are from a congressional
office study back in 1989 and if you're
thinking about starting an enterprise
it's always nice to see a potential
growth curve that's one of these it's
not quite bio technology but it has the
potential to be an industry which offers
relatively rapid growth if you look at
that top section can you is it focused
in the backers that kind of let's see
what we can do here there we go if you
look at that top pie chart 80% of the
circle is made up of aerospace and about
15% of is made up of Sporting Goods
what's those two industries have in
common is price is no object if you're a
golfer you can if you can hit the ball
10 yards further and it's going to stay
within the short grass really the price
that you're gonna pay is really not not
conditional on is it does it cost $50
more for a set of clubs
I won't even refer to the costs involved
with the America's Cup because all of us
have read the stories and heard about it
I think in the sporting goods world it's
a it's the closest thing that we could
ever come to in the 7 $700 hammer
category and that technology was heavily
applied with the with the ultimate
objective of winning a sailboat race so
there's another example that price
wasn't really an object if you can make
the button if you could make the
sailboat go faster but my contention was
and really an observation was that these
materials had the potential to be used
in broader applications than just
Sporting Goods and aerospace so where
does that lead us as a graduate student
23 years old I decided that we're an
opportunity lie was in windsurfing and
another thing which I found relatively
unique about my own experiences I think
I'm the only one who ever attended MIT
for the following two reasons first was
it had a sailing team and this is an
order of priority second I could study
naval architecture and at age 14 I
decided that the design of boats if I
what I really was was a professional
sailor at age 14 the design of boats was
probably the next best thing so really
when I
was a student at MIT that's really what
my focus was I sailed on the
intercollegiate intercollegiate team I
did an Olympic campaign in 1984 in the
fin class and really that's what that's
what really made me tick I was highly
focused on sailing to refer windsurfing
to sailing in many ways is like
referring skiing to snowboarding there
are almost two different sports entirely
the people that sail oftentimes don't
have anything to do with windsurfing
it's sort of like windsurfing as kids
and people that sail sit down when they
sail and they have cocktails and they go
on the New York Yacht Club cruise and
those kind of things
windsurfing is really rock music and
kids and it's high-energy and its
jumping and sailing forty or fifty miles
an hour but what the opportunity was was
for the use of a composite material in a
windsurfer and this is a section of a
windsurfer mass I'll just pass it around
the audience to give people a feel the
thing that's most noticeable about is it
it's extremely light it's about half of
the weight of aluminum and it's
significantly stronger and that's why in
a case like the America's Cup boats
where there was really high premium on
reducing weight to improve performance
people there was a willingness for
people to use alternative material sauce
I'll circulate this we our company this
year will produce more than a million
linear feet of this tubing and what that
has led us to be able to develop is some
very innovative manufacturing
technologies which have the potential to
use these types of structural materials
and other applications so I'm going to
interrupt this discussion with a with a
five-minute info infomercial here to
give you an idea exactly of how this
very lightweight and high strength
material material is actually used in a
windsurfing application so Ralph we'll
start with you we can pass that around
so what I'm gonna put on here is this is
a video that is kind of really a balance
between a marketing video but also it
really illustrates the technology
involved with combining fibers of
different types with a polymer or
plastic material and the resulting
material results very improved
properties when compared to conventional
materials such as aluminum so I don't
know if we need to turn the lights down
but let's give this a try
[Music]
Viper's farm maths
the lightest strongest and most durable
carbon-fiber windsurfing masts in the
world you know whether mast available
today demonstrates the same strength at
such a lightweight
[Music]
in comparison tests designed to measure
how far a mass can bend before it breaks
the competitions maths don't measure up
in test after test fibre spar masts
consistently demonstrate the ability to
bend twice as far as their competitors
[Music]
Peter Quigley began working with
composite materials at MIT in 1980 and
developed the patented laminate that
gives fiber spar the unique properties
of lightness strength and Bend ability
what the bend
translates directly into is durability
and strength if you can bend further
than the next guy you've got a stronger
[Music]
it's the combination of incredible
strength and low weight that defines the
fibrous bar difference Nevin Sayer
professional world cup racer and
three-time national champion has been
using fiber spar masts and booms since
1986 and has been instrumental in their
development well on professional ranks
everyone that is so good that the
equipment often is making a difference
and most of the guys we were sponsored
by different sponsors they have
different pours different sales etc the
one thing that is fairly constant is the
fact that we all use masks made by
fibrous bark
the rigs are lighter they're more
durable they're easier to control people
can do things on windsurfing that they
never could before the fiber spar
difference begins with the unique and
highly specialized manufacturing process
carbon fibers are interlaced with two
different fiberglass yarns to create a
seamless tri-axial structure the masts
are constructed to be light at the top
with a lower center of gravity for
easier handling the entire profile is
narrowed to smooth the flow of air for
superior aerodynamics fiber spars
specialized manufacturing process means
superior reflex response your mast
recovers quicker after a gust or pump
for instant acceleration and increased
speed in fact fiber spar carbon masts
recover four times faster than
fiberglass and twice as fast as aluminum
most importantly fiber spar masts are
engineered to withstand just about
anything you can treat the equipment in
a way
that allows you while you're on the
water to be as aggressive and go for it
as much as you possibly can and the
equipment is not going to be the weak
part it may be your body as important as
the equipment is for professionals
beginners needed to they need the
lightest mass the most durable mass and
the mass that's easiest to use at Rhonda
Smith's windsurfing Center at the gorge
and Hood River Oregon fiber sparse
lighter masts make windsurfing easier
and more enjoyable to learn just
recently I had a woman in one of my
clinics who could not get her sail out
of the water I went over to help her I
tried to get her sail out of the water
I couldn't I turned to her and said
you've got to get a fiber spar mass the
water Striders are benefiting the most I
mean they can now just lift the sail up
effortlessly it's not a bench-pressed
anymore
fiber spar has developed a series of
tests to measure the critical
performance characteristics of their
masts to be sure that specifications for
quality and consistency are met the T
tests ensure that the mast will maintain
its designed curve stiffness and reflex
response over years of demanding use
other tests measure the forces that a
mask can withstand and of course we
check to see how far it can bend before
it breaks but before the fiber spar
label goes on every mast must pass the
Quality Assurance test first load cells
measure the weight and center of gravity
next the mast is checked for proper
curve and stiffness
finally each mast is subjected to a
strength test to ensure structural
integrity when the green lights come on
you can be assured that the mast has met
all of fiber spars strict specifications
mast curve and stiffness determine both
performance and power without the right
mast your sail won't perform to its
potential to ensure optimum performance
fiber spar engineers work closely with
leading sail makers to maintain their
comprehensive mast sail compatibility
guy no matter what level of sailor you
are the advantages are Pyrus bars
lightweight masts are obvious as soon as
you try them superior reflex response
means greater acceleration and overall
speed the narrow diameter means better
aerodynamics and easier handling state
of the art engineering results in a
lightweight mass that is built to last
and most importantly quality is
guaranteed every mast we make passes the
Quality Assurance test
[Music]
go faster with more control Sam longer
with less effort once you experience the
fibrous bar difference you'll wonder how
you ever sailed without it okay I
thought the reason that would be
interesting to show is really something
really unusual happened while I was in
it while I was here at MIT in fact in
launching this venture I really became
not a sailor
in other words wind surfing was so
different from the sailing experience
that I had what it really became was
really a business opportunity and and
also a personal challenge in terms of to
try and start with an application where
these materials were really not well
accepted what was revealing about those
bending tests is that carbon fiber has
typically been assumed to be a very
brittle material it can be very stiff
and very light but typically you can't
fabricate structures which can be
subjected to such extreme bending
bending loads and to really try and
commercialize based on this very narrow
product a company that was based on
innovation in manufacturing so we're
located an hour southeast of Boston I'm
happy to say since 1989 when we really
began production in earnest a windsurfer
mast our employment we now have 65
full-time employees
we've been literally running about
between two shifts a day and three
shifts a day six days a week since 1989
we supplied all of the masts to the
Olympic competitors in 1992 every single
competitor use masts made by fiber spar
and the the real innovation from my
perspective is not just in the
development of the business based on
what you perceive is a very narrow niche
but also the opportunities we have to
expand based on the innovation and
manufacturing so what I have is just to
illustrate a couple of points where
where I think that this is going and
where we as an organization are trying
to position ourselves to capitalize and
here's a couple of things I've selected
one particular
industry because I think people in this
room many of us here have some affinity
or some affiliation with the ocean
engineering department here at MIT which
is celebrating as all of us know it's a
hundredth anniversary and one of the
things that I've selected just for an
illustration is one was a symposium
hosted in Washington the National
Academy of Sciences which was looking
there's nothing really magical about
this except just to really illustrate
that these materials are moving and have
the potential to move beyond these very
high-end sporting goods or aerospace
applications this conference was called
in 1991 and coincidentally it was at the
at the point where the aerospace
companies were desperate to try and find
new applications for composite material
so this conference was I would say 95%
attended by aerospace engineers and
executives trying to get together with
people in the marine industry to see if
there may be some potential but this was
looking up because of the lightweight
and high-strength corrosion resistant
properties that a composite may offer
some potential applications in the
marine environment and here's another
example where for offshore structures
again the symposium hosted MIT this one
much smaller but attending I would say
they were probably 75 attendees of all
the major oil companies in the world
each of them probably had two or three
of their senior R&D people attending
this if you will a very exploratory
discussion more or less on what
potential applications for advanced
composite materials might there be in
the offshore industry where corrosion
exposure to marine environment or really
caustic chemicals in many cases a desire
to reduce weight if the structure is
being supported by hydrostatic forces
etc so I guess what what I'd like to
just share with you today is really from
the experience as a student at MIT and
initially as a sailor and an athlete the
discipline and I think the focus that I
had as as a student and the focus of
energy and sailing led to that initial
identification of the opportunity which
was the wind surfer mast even though I
didn't win surf myself and I think what
we see as an organization is the
potential to crossover where we really
are based
Manufacturing and our innovation we feel
is in being able to produce high volumes
of product at low cost and they're
sophisticated but to begin as our
company continues to grow to diversify
into markets that have potential to be a
broader utility let's say then the
manufacturer windsurfer mouth so I'd
like to just thank the opportunity here
that I've had to share with you my own
experience great
[Applause]
what your mass actually have some glass
in them right yeah what's the purpose of
the glass well actually there are two
different types of glass in the master
and what composite is is it's really if
people have heard of this expression of
an engineered material you can tailor
the properties of the structure based on
what its requirements are so for example
a windsurfer mast it has a required
requirement to be extremely strong and
bending but then also where the Sailor
is attached to the mast there's extreme
point loading he holds on just by that
boom and you can imagine the forces when
the person lands in the water
unfortunately I keep myself in the water
at any time I went there I don't try and
go out of the water so there's an
example where radial loads and also
external impact was a real factor so we
add a glass to improve the toughness of
the laminate by basically just adding
wall thickness essentially so really
it's it's in many ways the analogy isn't
not too dissimilar to cooking and that
you have in a composite material a lot
of different ingredients there may be
Kevlar fiber different varieties of
carbon fiber different types of glass
fiber and a whole host of polymer
matrices that you combine in different
ways to achieve some desired properties
so that that's why they're so fun to mix
I tried very hard to get a composite
waiting on the 777 but
that wasn't going to happen I left
bullying and helped build with America's
company when I talk to my buddies at
Boeing they say well don't come back and
tell you can bring the cost down to
something
so my question to you is are you
well that masked actually we sell to our
OEM customer for average probably $75
yeah and one of the things about it's a
it's a misconception about composite
materials that people think they're
expensive because the materials are
expensive but oftentimes what you see is
the manufacturing cost is so prohibitive
that that's actually a larger driver
because it's just imagine if aluminum
was a novel material or plastic was
novel people didn't have extrusion
machines or they didn't have the kinds
of apparatus necessary to produce things
that were useful so so I feel and one of
the things that's motivating it can ask
in 1986 why get into a manufacturing
company in Massachusetts I think the
innovation and the potential for
innovation in manufacturing can really
lead to cost reductions
well the problem is an insert if a
windsurfer breaks the guy falls in the
water for the airplane breaks all right
out here Peter are there any in the
windsurfing that community now are there
any sort of like vinyl healthy
proponents out there that like like the
old style masts for any sort
it's pretty it's pretty like a aluminum
when we started was a dominant material
and it's the analogy to tennis is very
similar you can't buy a wooden tennis
racket now even for the cheapest price
same is happening with with composites
the prices are going lower and lower
but maybe Kim shy-shy pass on here or
take another question I think one more
the gentleman out here then well
Sporting Goods is so rich for
application of these materials in almost
every sporting goods industry whether
it's bicycles or skis composite
technology is being applied there's a
new development in ski design where
instead of making the ski as a box where
you have a structural material like wood
as a core they're going to very
lightweight skins that have essentially
cores that have no internal strength and
they cap the ski so there's this notion
of a cap ski and I think you're the same
is true in archery the same is true and
fishing and fly-fishing I mean in
sporting goods because people like I say
are really willing to pay the price for
the advances and the prices of the
composites are what's keep going to keep
the materials out of more you know more
diverse and broader applications but
maybe maybe one thing I'd like to say
they're really two of my mentors here
that are also in the panel and Jerry was
an undergraduate advisor of mine in the
ocean engineering department and Ted Van
Dusen who founded a company composite
engineering who I respect very much also
while I was a student allowed me as an
undergraduate and after I left the
Institute to really experiment with in
his own facility while Ted was
developing technologies for the
manufacturing of growing shell so I just
want to say really thanks to both of you
and it's partly a reflection on them
that this activity has gone for thank
you here
and we'll move on to Ted Van Deusen Ted
do you need the movable mic no it's a
pleasure to be before all of you and
tell you about what I've been doing
Society left the Institute and I have a
series of slides to describe it
let's see if I can find the Jerry I know
you kicked a lot of things that's true I
don't think I'll have as traumatic a
talk as the other two but I'll see what
I can do come from a background at web
Institute and then MIT and along the way
I'd had an opportunity to get some work
experience both at a large shipyard and
a small design concern and I wanted to
be involved in a company that was doing
design and development but I also wanted
to have the stability of manufacturing
and be able to really get down to make
things happen rather than just do
designs on paper and hope that someone
else figured out what you wanted in and
did it to what standards I had and it
seemed like I'd been a competitive
athlete and a naval architect and I
developed a shell that seemed to be
winning on a local basis and it seemed
to me sports equipment was a nice way to
go to company started because if you had
something slightly better it had an
immediate market and something that you
could start producing a limited number
of getting enough money to go into a
larger company so I started building
rowing shells and this is kind of
another view of one of our earlier boats
we were one of the first people to
design a boat using composite materials
because we wanted to make a lighter
stiffer boat and we pretty much copied a
lot of the wood construction there was a
outer skin and
a truss framework inside to carry the
load and one of the problems we had was
just trying to make room for the athlete
in the middle of the boat where we would
have to get the athlete's feet fairly
low and just where the loads are highest
in the boat you have to cut a big hole
for the athlete so we tended to carry
the loads through stringers in the boat
and you can kind of see a little bit
what it looks like there we ended up
being very fortunate in 1976 the year I
really got the company started in that
women were allowed to compete in rowing
for the first time and in the Olympics
and the US women were considered to be
very far behind the Iron Curtain
countries but our best single scholar
Joan Lin managed to come off with a
silver medal and a very spectacular
finish and in winning the trials to
represent this country I think there are
only been three races that are at boats
haven't won continuously since 1976 in
choosing the best single scholar for
both men and women and it was just a
fortunate thing that this happened just
as we were getting going and in the
early 80s the US Olympic Committee did a
study of how the u.s. fared in the world
in different sports and they discovered
that the sports requiring very little
equipment which they determine ology
sports would be like running swimming
things like that we did very well in and
sports like skiing cycling rowing that
required a lot of technique and
equipment the u.s. fared worse than
expected and they set aside some R&D
money to try to change that situation
because it seemed like the US with all
his technology should be doing better
than anybody else in the world I put
some proposals in and gotten some grant
money to do some tank testing and my
previous designs of wrong shells was
based on trying to estimate and
extrapolate from what literature was
available of tests
votes and this is my first opportunity
to get into the towing tank and doing
some testing and we took a parametric
study of four different kayak hull
variations and tested another for
existing racing boats and one of our
tank models tested with one and a half
percent less drag than the best racing
boats out there and we very quickly took
a mold off it and made a few kayaks and
the first two we delivered competed in
the pan-american games in 1987 and won
two gold medals and then a month later
went to the World Championships in the
US won the first two gold medals and
everyone in kayaking in the history of
the sport and this is a photo of the
fellow finishing Greg Barton happened to
be one of developing paddlers have been
working very hard and was just reaching
his top performance level we'd hired a
top European coach for kayaking and he
was upgrading our whole level of
competition and then with the new boat
we'd like to think that was part of the
whole formula for winning and what's
unusual about this his style is that
he's got such a lead you can't see any
of the other boats in the frame he won
by the second largest winning margin in
the history of the sport and he's just
coasting across the line based on this
success we were asked to do a complete
fleet of kayaks k1 k2 k4 in canoes for
the 1988 Olympics and this Greg Barton
and then he want to get a gold medal
again which was the first gold in ever
won an Olympic competition and then an
hour later teamed up with a another
fellow and won a thousand-meter k2 event
and this is the first time that dual
wins within an hour had ever been pulled
off and was the first our first two
golds ever so it was quite a nice feat
to
I've just got a couple shots here this
shows a canoe they're kind of unusual
craft built to Olympic specifications
the main difference I would notice
between a kayak and canoe as a canoe has
to have a single bladed paddle in a
kayak has a double bladed paddle
I wanted to say a little bit about the
competition theory many of the sports
are being pressed very hard because the
Olympics are getting so crowded and
sports like kayaking and rowing only
have about half the countries that are
entered in the Olympics participating in
these sports and they're trying very
hard to keep the costs low and the
equipment fair between all the athletes
and it seems to me that what we're
trying to do is to find the best athlete
and equipment can lose the race and this
this should be fairly small differences
between equipment so that it's not going
to make a winner
for someone so if you did come through
with a breakthrough that would probably
create an unfair advantage and get
controlled by the race regulatory bodies
but at the same time we've seen the
sport evolve from fairly wide heavy
boats a century or two centuries ago
into very sleek boats that are very hard
to handle and every athlete has his own
abilities in terms of conditioning and
strength and what we need is equipment
that suits the individual athlete to be
able to for them to perform at their
best and what we've tried to do is make
things as adjustable as possible but
just the fact that we have one
particular model doesn't mean that
that's the answer for everyone and
there's been some move to try to make
one design boats to cut lower costs but
in effect by the choosing the design of
the boats you're choosing the athlete
and we have tried quite hard to keep
that open in going ahead and trying to
improve the boats I broke up my design
effort into two areas one was to improve
handling trying to make it more natural
and easy to use the more the athlete can
relax the better they can perform at by
the time you get to the top
international level just about every
athlete is in top condition and very
often the difference between winning and
losing is how relaxed you are in the
boat
improve safety these boats are pretty
safe but every once in a while you hear
of an accident where someone's caught
out in a storm and something happens and
just improve safety allows you to train
longer in the year and then we're trying
to figure out ways of increasing the
athletes useful work and that would kind
of go along with relaxing like I said
having the various adjustments and
equipment be the one that would match
the athletes ability to put power out
and the water through the oars or
paddles be able to accept that energy
the other side of design is trying to
reduce the drag and other losses in the
system and that's really much easier to
approach really what we're trying to do
is combine an art of figuring out what
the human interface is and combining
that with the technology of reducing the
drag and increasing performance when to
start a little bit on talking about
handling this is the women's two-person
kayak k2 that qualified for the 1988
Olympics you can see that the center of
gravity is quite high and the boats
quite narrow with the new kayaking
stroke the paddles extend a fair
distance out to the side of the boat and
one of the unusual things is all of the
boats I'm talking about here are
completely unstable you put them in the
water before you get in and they want to
roll over you get in with a high center
of gravity and it's almost ridiculous
you if you aren't skilled at it you'd
never really be able to keep them up in
fact any designer who had never seen
this evolution would be considered crazy
to design a boat that couldn't be
paddled the interesting thing is the
first pack I showed you I designed and I
said well you know I've been rowing for
20 years
I'm used to a long skinny boat I better
try this out before I deliver it so I
went down to the local beach with my
friend who had done a lot of regular
canoeing with
we got in the boat
I kind of rested the paddle and the
water tried to get my balance I couldn't
even pick the paddle up to take a stroke
before I went over we tried for about
half an hour and decided it was
completely unpadded well but I had to
take the boat down and deliver it anyway
Greg Barton got in and pushed off the
dock
oh this feels fine so I spent the next
two years swimming and eventually
learning how to stay up I wanted to show
this slide for stability this is just
scale you can see that the cross-section
of the boat and the water is extremely
small the athletes it's just about with
the seat at water height on the right I
have a rigid rotation of the athlete
turning with the boat and this is very
much what happens when a novice gets in
a boat they're rigid they don't relax
and for a certain amount of angular
rolling the center of gravity moves
quite a bit to the side of the center of
buoyancy those of you that are familiar
with stability realize that you can pick
up and here's the metacenter and if the
center of gravity is below the
metacenter the boat is stable and
generally most ships are designed with
several feet of metacentric height here
we've got
there's analogy to that the restoring
force to bring the boat back to upright
is proportional to the righting moment
or restoring moment on a pendulum and
I've drawn on the side here pendulum so
you can see on the right that pendulum
is quite high and upside down it's quite
an art to keep these boats upright on
the
left I've got a sketch with the athlete
it's very relaxed and is balancing
himself to sit vertically and the boat
rolls and you can see that his center of
gravity deflects very much less so the
art in doing the design here is trying
to understand what the athlete is going
through and using the equipment trying
to push the design as far as you can to
reduce the drag but still make it
palpable or rollable and one of the
things is that when people go to
organize a race and everybody gets there
for a major Olympics it has to be
life-threatening conditions for them to
want to call off a race and you find
that you have to race in almost every
kind of condition out there and maybe
there aren't huge waves but there's a
lot of wind
there are various wakes and other things
and you pretty much have to have a boat
that does everything well that it's
going to sea
in trying to reduce the drag on boats we
tried to figure out several different
areas where we find a reduction in drag
we had a fairly limited budget so we
would be stuck only trying to test half
a dozen different models and two or
three different boats as controls this
shows us testing full sizes
jari Milgram pointed out the scale
effects are really quite difficult to
compensate for and we're dealing with
boats that have evolved for several
centuries and the difference between the
best and the worst boat at a Olympic
competition is probably about four
percent and drag and most of them much
less than that in trying to assess the
effect of a change you're really trying
to read tenths of a percent difference
in the tank tests you don't have the
budget to do it statistically to figure
out just what's going on and it took the
most difficult protocol in terms of
setting up and measuring everything the
boats are so long and skinny they
deflect a little bit in the water so
we'd have to measure just exactly how
they're sitting in the water and try to
figure out what I'm plotting here the
results of drag test this is a single
shell it operates in a race pace
somewhere between four and five meters
per second bearing during each stroke
and starting at the top line the top
curve shows the resistance of moving
through still air for the athlete the
boat and the oars and the next section
below that is the wave drag and you can
see it's quite small and this is because
the boats are extremely long and slender
and there's the bulk of the drag is
viscous drag or frictional drag and
everybody says well why don't you make
the boat smaller and cut down the wetted
surface and what happens is as soon as
you make the boat smaller it becomes
less slender and the wave drag increases
much more dramatically than you save in
cutting down the wetted surface area
shells are actually built slightly
longer than they should be for minimum
drag at steady speed and that's because
the athletes sliding back and forth in
the boat and it depressing the bow and
the stern alternately and you can pick
up some added drag from doing that it's
it's been a very hard thing to figure
out just how to test that accurately and
we haven't done unsteady tests although
there have been a few estimates that
it's in the order about 4% of the total
drag
we've tried to take that into account in
the design but it ends up suggesting
that you both be two or three feet
longer than what it would be if you were
testing steady-state for comparison this
is the drag off a k1 again it races
slightly shorter distance but just about
steady four and a half meters per second
and the top curve again is aerodynamic
drag somewhat less it doesn't have oars
and you're sitting a little lower the
viscous drag is considered as
considerably less and the wave drag is
considerably more this is because the
boats are required to meet certain
length and width rules that k1 is five
point two meters or roughly 17 feet and
this is about two or three feet too
short for ideal performance although if
you could make a boat a little longer
like that you'd have to sit higher
because you could no longer fit the seat
is low and it's not sure whether it'd be
a faster boat or not what's interesting
is the two boats have almost identical
total drags and they both go just about
the same speed
just wanted to make some notes on
structural design we want to make the
boat as rigid and as light as possible
they're very highly stressed in terms of
fatigue so you have to be careful on the
design for that and you'd like to keep
his lowest center of gravity as possible
to aid instability the first shell I
built I designed to have about 1% less
dragged in the boat I'd been rowing
loaded extensively and couldn't find
that it was any faster at all and then I
went back to the MIT library and started
looking at what happens when you have a
more flexible boat and determined that I
could account for most of the lack of
improvement due to the vibrations in the
hull because I designed a more flexible
Hall even though it was lighter and I
was tripping the boundary layer laminar
flow to turbulent much earlier and it
gained about the % drag that I had
thought I was saving and ever since the
beginning our company has tried to make
extremely stiff boats other observations
I want to make here is it just the
flexibility and the footboard the seed
and the rigors anything that the athlete
has to work with seems to absorb energy
it delays the time that you can actually
start to apply power it's a very dynamic
thing to be able to get the stroke the
with the or paddle in the water and it
get full force and then get it out at a
stroke rates and rowing in the 30 to 35
strokes a minute in kayaking during a
sprint they'll get up into over a
hundred strokes a minute so you want
everything associated with the athlete
that they're pushing off to be as rigid
as possible
you need the hull is a beam to be rigid
but you need to have some flexibility in
the system an athlete is not going to
put the or paddle in the water at
exactly the speed the water's moving all
the time and if there isn't a little bit
of flexibility in the or a paddle to
absorb that mismatch you get wear and
tear injuries on your joints so it's a
thing that has to be quite carefully
tuned into the athlete this just shows a
sketch of the loading on a single shell
you've got the crew weight in the middle
of fairly minimal hull weight dispersed
over the boat and then the water weight
supporting it and this is just a scale
to show you how slender the boat is and
it's really quite a challenge that
required us to get into composites we
built our first boats using Kevlar and
boron with some wood the price of boron
was about two hundred and fifty dollars
a pound and carbon fiber was about four
hundred dollars a pound when he built
our first shells
since then carbon has come down to being
the $13 a pound range and Boren stated
200 plus so now we're doing a lot in
carbon fiber this just shows a layup of
one of our single shell hulls in the
shop we start with a mold that's covered
with a gel coat and then we lay fabric
and Nomex honeycomb in the boat we
basically have to be quite careful to
get it all in right we've got the
different layers going in every
direction imaginable to try to get this
strength the way we want and when it's
all done we throw a sheet of plastic
over it and seal it to the mold and then
draw a vacuum in the space and that uses
atmospheric pressure to compact the
laminate and draw any air that's trapped
between the plies out and then we put it
into a pressure vessel I'll call it an
autoclave bring it up to several
atmospheres pressure and bring it up to
250 degrees Fahrenheit at which point
the resin flows and cures
this is the structure in our one of our
early shells their stringers along each
side forming the gunnels and the keel
those are braided back in about 1975 we
realized that we wanted to make
longitudinal stringers with carbon and
tried to find a nice way to do it no one
was really weaving carbon at any
attractive price at that time and I
bought some old textile braiders and
adapted them to work with composites and
made the structure of the boat inside
also this yellow tubes which are
actually arrows from Impala niro company
very light tubing and then at the end I
had to make a lug to adapt it and all of
those are little grated end lugs that
all have mold so every few degrees
difference angle down the boat they had
to be a different mold it was quite
time-consuming to put a structure
together like this but it avoided a lot
of stress concentrations and many rowing
shells either in wood or other composite
materials have the reputation of after
five years or so of hard use of starting
to soften up and get more limber and
they would then be relegated to training
purposes and it seemed to me that once
an athlete bought a boat they should be
able to compete for a long time in that
boat it takes quite a while to adjust a
boat and adapt it to yourself and we
tried to design any stress
concentrations and fatigue out of the
system and we've taken boats back now
about 20 years old and measured their
stiffness compared to measurements we
made early on and they've seem to hold
their stiffness very well so it's what
it was a good thing for us in that are
the resale value our boats have stayed
very high and they've been quite
desirable this is a picture of one of
the newest boats we just came up with a
new design in time for the last Olympics
and we were moving away from that
internal structure with all of the frame
work just because of the time-consuming
nature we ended up with a much more
sculptured aerodynamic boat our previous
boat was more like a wooden boat in
construction and this has no sharp
corners and
it's made with uni-directional carbon
fiber taped its place so it can kind of
go around the cockpit and avoid the
stress concentrations we also were quite
concerned about aerodynamic drag and you
can see the outriggers supporting the
oars are a kind of an airfoil shape and
instead of the multiple tube round tube
that's normally there and we were
expecting to save a little less than 1%
in the total resistance and as a
undergraduate product project some
students put one of our riggers in a
wind tunnel and found about 1/8 tenths
of a percent drag reduction so we're
quite pleased by that and a few of the
other manufacturers have talked about oh
well we tried that and it didn't work
well I think most athletes have trouble
noticing in terms of just the feel of a
boat when this would change in drag less
than 1% and I think the whole goal of
this adventure is to try to add up
several small changes until you really
have something this was just one of the
details this just is the finish of the
last Olympics in Barcelona that boat at
the top is being rowed by Anne Martin
she's won a silver at the previous
Olympics and is was running in 2nd to
3rd place for most of the race and is
just losing to the Canadian in the
wooden boat in the final sprint and she
ended up fourth it's the first Olympics
the US has competed in since 76 that we
haven't gotten as a medal in women's
singles calling even though the boat was
by far better than anything we've done
before but that's just how it goes
sometimes
this shows a an a toward shell that we
built using the airfoil riggers some of
these are just so you can get a feel for
what the different boats look like
although many of you probably have spent
a lot of time in it
this shows a training camp in Florida
going into this past Olympics there was
a feeling we might be able to improve on
the drag of that single kayak that we
designed back in 1988 and we had the
chance to go back in and do some more
tank testing varying some other
parameters tested for more hauls and
ended up with a one and three quarter
percent drag reduction on top of the
other boat so we went into the Olympics
with very high hopes Gregg Barton's in
the foreground here paddling it handles
slightly differently but nothing that
anybody couldn't adapt to he ended up
not being able to repeat his victory
ended up taking a bronze medal but it
still was quite good here's Greg teamed
up with his partner that they silver
meddled in the previous Olympics in
Barcelona and again they just missed the
medals one of the things I noticed in
competition at this last Olympics was
that there were very few totally
outstanding athletes there were head and
shoulders above everybody else in
previous Olympics there were you'd often
see someone that was clearly better now
it seemed like there were half a dozen
people that could be on the podium
getting a gold medal and it was really
all kinds of little subtle factors as to
whether they won that particular day and
the competition was extremely close
we had about 45 of our boats being
represented in the Olympics and from
starting first building kayaks in 1987
it's really shows how quickly you can
kind of sweep into top international
circles if you have a better boat
this shows the US women in a k4 it's
quite a fast boat
and another shot of a canoe
along with the boat development we
worked in on paddles and going into the
88 Olympics a couple of years ahead of
time
Swedish harridan amesys noticed the top
Swedish paddlers were paddling with what
they considered was a defect in style
where the paddle was going out from the
side of the boat as opposed to coming
straight back and previous to then to
his work paddles were basically drag
devices and he'd invented this paddle
called a wing paddle which is really a
thin airfoil and in a couple years
preceding the 88 Olympics all the top
athletes changed to it and no one made
the finals in 88 without having one of
these paddles and it's been an evolution
since then we've tried eight or nine
different designs and as the paddle is
moving backward and twist and moving in
someone's hand it's very much like
Repeller advancing sideways away from
the boat and it has needs to be twisted
which this original paddle wasn't and we
did quite a bit of tank testing and
video analysis of the paddle stroke here
we just saw several different designs
that we had tufted and we would have a
paddle or go down a towing tank with an
underwater window and take videos of
what was going on and trying to optimize
the flow what happens though is that you
find you need about 30 or 40 degrees
twists in the paddle to get the optimum
lift at the sections all the way up and
down the paddle in the middle of the
stroke but the flow changes from almost
coming you know at the end of the paddle
to going crosswise and then a little bit
on the paddle so it changes through
about 130 degrees through the stroke so
it's such a compromise in flow direction
that the trick is to try to get the
paddle to work well at all different
parts of the stroke and they've been
some major improvements in that area in
terms of the way the paddle feels and
times have dropped a typical time for a
500 meter sprint would be about a
hundred seconds and
the times have dropped about four
seconds due to the change in the paddle
so this is one of the kind of the major
revolutions in sports kind of like a
fiberglass pole vault or something else
it's really had quite significant effect
I've also been quite involved in sailing
this is one of my love's and
international sailing canoe we built our
first carbon-fiber mast in 1978 for a
505 and then got involved in the small
dinghy classes that allowed carbon which
is predominantly now 505 I'm sorry
international 14s and international
canoes and for the small dinghies the
reduction in weight of course paid off
in just less displacement and less drag
but really affected the dynamics of the
boat performing in waves they just have
a much better emotion because the boats
are sailed up right
only at manoeuvres when you're likely to
make a mistake in capsized as the weight
weight really affect anything to do with
stability but I was just at our national
championships in the international canoe
and there was not a single boat there
that didn't have a carbon-fiber mast the
nice thing was the only one we didn't
built broke we had quite a storm come
through was about a 35 not breeze so
it's kind of tough on these little boats
recently we've been trying to get
involved in larger boat mass but I just
have a photo here of a close-up of the
braiding technology we used to make
those bars and we've got longitudinal
carbons hoop wrap of carbon showing
vertically on this slide frame and then
you can see little glass yarns going at
plus or minus roughly 45 degrees and we
find the addition of a little bit of s
glass in the carbon greatly toughen up
the mast we have about 10 percent s
glass in the total and as with sail
boards probably less so these masts tend
to get quite a bit of abuse and if you
start a little crack or if you have
holes around the fitting it's very nice
to have a tougher material in there to
prevent a crack from spreading and the
ultimate elongation of carbon fibers
and a half to two percent to failure and
the s-class is around seven percent so
the two materials work very well
together this is the largest mast we've
built to date it's a 92 foot spar for a
single-handed around-the-world racer and
just shows a other shot of it underway
we've used the same braiding technology
just with a larger Raider one of the
things that is really nice about
braiding is that it will form the fibers
around any kind of mandrel you put in
there and it's very easy to make shapes
that are tapered in section and also
tapered in wall thickness and one of the
harder things to accomplish in
production kind of manufacturing is to
be able to do tapered wall thicknesses
and this lets someone go in there and
say okay I have this particular load I
want this much fiber in this direction
actually weave it the way you want with
long continuous yarns with no lobster
bonds to worry about it's really quite a
powerful technology and Peter told you
about how he was able to specialize his
company from making many small parts and
getting a very attractive price we've
tried to aim toward going to larger
custom parts so we're doing very much of
the same thing from time to time we get
opportunity to work on unusual boats
this is an Australian 18-foot skiff it's
a we did this eight or nine years ago it
did very well in the World Championships
and is on display in the Sydney nautical
museum it's a kind of an exercise in
carbon fiber and honeycomb they're quite
unusual boats and then a designer had us
build a unusual hydrofoil sail boat
again another exercise and carbon fiber
I was quite skeptical of this thing ever
flying
my focus is a little tough but it
actually got up and sailed quite well
the main problems were involved in not
enough R&D going into the sale control
but it lifted off and sailed quite
quickly one other somewhat related
technology that we've been involved in
is wind power
it doesn't really follow in the marine
area other than the fact that most
aerodynamic codes are written for making
propulsive power out of propellers and
the design codes are really quite
different when you want to take energy
out of the wind and the general naval
architecture background that one gets at
the Institut here really prepares one
well to go from original principles into
studying a new technology and I've been
involved in forming the largest wind
power company in the world as one of
four founders for that called us wind
power and they're generating enough
power about equal to two nuclear power
plants so we're saving quite a bit of
energy either in terms of fossil fuel or
nuclear waste and hopefully not burning
hydrocarbons will somehow help the ocean
environment this shows the test set of
blades we made that the Department of
Energy is testing different air foils at
at Rocky Flats in Colorado this is a
little better shot of AB Rader I didn't
know Peter was going to show you a one
in motion which is far better than a
still shot that's why I included this
this shows one of our blades under
construction we've got a two skins one
down and one opened up with a lot of
instrumentation we had a few hundred
little pressure tubes in there to
measure the pressure in the airfoil and
strain gauges and then there's a wet out
braided tube in there that's got a
bladder inside and soon as we close the
pieces up we're going to pressurize the
bladder and past the spar right into the
skin and the spar is the main
load-carrying member the skins just kind
of smoothes the airflow
this is just a shot of one of the wind
sites in California they're really quite
dramatic if you haven't seen them
they're just hundreds of windmills over
all the hills and it was a natural wind
site because this particular one is just
east of San Francisco Golden Gate Bridge
they've got annual average wind speeds
of about 23 miles an hour so there's
quite a bit of energy to capture and
there's a large aqueduct going to
Southern California with pumped storage
facility in the water so if you generate
electricity and someone doesn't need it
right away you can raise the water and
then get the energy back out and we've
seen quite a large development there
this is my shop in Concord Massachusetts
about 18 miles from here I'd love to
give anybody a tour if they're out that
way so just stop in and that's all I
have to say thank you
[Applause]
question or two and then we'll get on to
our last speaker right here basically
what we do is we try to understand the
paddle motion used by the top athletes
and then represent the inflow angles
throughout the paddle during different
parts of the stroke and then try to
figure out it's pretty obvious if the
top part of the paddle is pushing
forward through the water that it's
acting as drag and slowing up the system
so you try to rotate the thing around
just do basic engineering the thing is
after you do that you go give the paddle
or the paddle and if you've got say 40
degrees twisting the paddle when he goes
to put the paddle and the water spins in
his hand and you can't even get it in
the water to take a stroke so very much
of it has been saying well I know where
I can get an improvement now I've got to
make it usable and was most of our
effort has been on the human adaptive
side of things much more so than what
the America's Cup has I'd like to be
much further along in actually doing it
computationally but right now it's it's
very much more in the paddle design very
much more of let's think of a design
let's go out and see if someone can use
it and then go faster and it come back
do another design to correct for that
and it's very much an evolution based on
the people yes
tray of Springs water shine
there probably is although different
paddlers have different techniques but
in terms of one optimum you want to
since the paddle starts very close to
the side of the boat and travels outward
at about a 45 degree angle with this new
wing technology and if you do a
photograph or a series of videos with
the reference frame with the water you
find that the paddle actually goes
straight sideways away from the boat in
the water doesn't really travel
backwards at all but what you want to do
is have the boat as narrow as possible
one of the things I didn't mention is
that we changed the shape of the boat to
make the boat extremely narrow we put
the paddle in and we've gotten several
inches more paddle stroke with this new
paddle as for where the paddle comes out
it depends on just how the paddle
paddler likes to paddle and there we
have several different design paddlers
some like to come back or something like
to go out to the side more and turn over
at higher or lower Cadence's and if you
drag something that you'd actually look
back and see where the paddle was coming
out of the water
you'd have major stability problems I
think the best thing is to analyze
videos and I think from actually seeing
people move or the athletes watching
themselves they'll see where they look
awkward to see where they look natural
and you can kind of work toward that and
the other thing that's been very helpful
is just recently they've been some
fairly arc accurate speedometers that
you can time yourself over different
distances with and it seems like a
fairly tribulus thing except you realize
that all of these boats are surging
quite a bit every stroke and what
they've had to do is to work out the
circuitry to average over a number of
strokes and just start that average
period at exactly the same place in a
stroke and that's those have helped
people evolve to new shapes very good
you know it's been a big advantage okay
we're gonna have to move on here and
thank you very much
next speaker is Don Lou of American
Bureau of shipping
good afternoon my life after MIT when I
graduated here I went to work for one
company and that's the American Bureau
shipping and most of my life has been
with big ships like well tankers
container ships and commercial ships but
nevertheless I was asked to speak on
tourists submersibles and I think it's I
don't know first of all I'd like to ask
the audience has anybody ever been
aboard a tourists immersive or submarine
okay fine that's more than I've been I
have not been aboard them but we as
American Bureau of shipping we clasp
them and I think it's perhaps just a
change of venue that we've heard all
about boats on the surface we talked a
little bit about boats beneath the
surface basically the evolution of the
manned submersible industry is an
incredible story the purpose of
submersibles when they first began was
really do research and observation and
since then they've got really gone into
a commercial venue and vehicles that
were designed to carry one two or three
people are now designed to be much
bigger and to carry 40 to 50 people and
most of us people being civilians the
most remarkable aspect of the
submersible business is that this
evolution really occurred only during
the last thirty years and most of the
commercial business has been developed
over only the last ten years so there's
money in that but basically the design
and construction of submersibles must
meet certain design and safety standards
of a classification society such as the
American Bureau of shipping which I
worked for and I just mentioned a little
bit about class we establish and
administer rules for design construction
and the fabrication of marine structures
primarily big ships but we also cover
Turo submersibles and as a matter of
fact we class most of the submersibles
throughout the world
and classification certifies that a
vehicle possesses the structural
mechanical fitness to operate safe
safely they're currently about thirty
terrorist submersibles around the world
and Jacques Piccard is credited with
designing the first terrorist
submersible which went into service in
1964 at the Swiss exhibition at Lake
Geneva and it was an operation for about
50 months and it carried about 32,000
terrorists at the bottom of Lake Geneva
which is about 300 feet and after this
exciting start the interest submersible
development languished for about 20
years and then in 1985 a company in
Canada at the time called sub aquatics
was formed to design build and operate
her submersibles and if I can guess I
have the first slide I guess I had
this is a an Atlantis submersible and it
was built by Atlantis submarines as it's
called now in Vancouver Canada and it's
probably the first modern submersible
built again in 1985 this company is one
of the largest it currently has 12 of
them operating and they operate in very
nice areas were obviously the water is
very clear the operating Hawaii Grand
Cayman Islands
Barbados st. Thomas Guam Aruba in Mexico
that's where this company operates and
if you look at this this vessel looks
very familiar if you've been to
Disneyland or Disney World it looks very
much like the submersibles there are
this or not submersibles but the
submarines here are some facts about the
Atlantis submersibles the series one is
50 foot over all 13 foot beam 8 foot
draft that was the first that they
developed and it carried 28 passengers
and the series 2 and 3 were the later
versions they're a little bit bigger
they carried 46 passengers and again in
both cases they have a crew of two that
series one cost something like two and a
half million dollars and the series to
about 2.9 the only three million dollars
weight talking from 49 to 80 tons
operating depth series one and two 150
feet series 3 250 feet most of the
submarines operate at about less than
probably about 150 200 feet as you go
deeper there's always scuba divers and
and below a certain depth scuba diving
becomes a little more dangerous so they
try to keep it probably about 150 under
75 feet and again its class by our
company yes it's also insured
Dwain see basically there's seal water
tanks there's ballast tanks in the in
the end the vessel one of the things
about submersibles is safety so far
there's 30 operating there's been no no
loss of life and believe me that most
companies are very concerned about any
any accidents because all you need is
one accident one submersible and they're
probably all out of business because of
just the negative advertisement about
that but they do have on submarines they
have a fixed ballast system which is
weights and they can jettison the
ballast in case a submarine under waters
in any danger you can release the weight
and the submarine will always rise so
it's it's a very safe vehicle again
safety features there's a redundancy
throughout the system and there's also a
surface vessel escort vessel that's
above the submarine and I have some
pictures of that later it's always in
radio contact with the summary below and
also there's navigation system to board
this is an Atlantis submarine out of the
water and it's constructed of a steel
cylindrical hole
there's a there's the steal Hall and
then above it this is fiberglass and
then beneath that there's some skids for
landing on the bottom and then there's
thrusters that you see for and also
after it's propelled by electrical
thrusters and powered by large banks of
batteries
this shows the interior view of the
Atlanta sub and the batteries are hidden
underneath the seats all under here and
this one here I think is a 48 passenger
vessel the battery box is equipped with
hydrogen detectors to warn the pilot of
any malfunction and the batteries have
to be recharged overnight for about up
to eight or ten hours so they all the
the the submarines operate during the
day recharge during the night here's a
bird's eye view of the pilot at his
controls in the nose of the pressure
hole and it almost looks like an
airplane cockpit and also the guy that
drives this thing is called a pilot and
not a captain this is a photo of another
submersible and this is not Atlanta
submarines but it's a it's called the
Sinbad and this tourist submersible is a
mark three and it's built by a company
and turku finland again that's another
very large manufacturer and it's again
designed to carry 46 passengers in a
crew of two and maximum depth of this
vessel is also 250 feet and this
particular one is operating in Egypt and
there's also sister vessels that are
operating in France in Majorca Spain and
in Taiwan
here's another mark three sub and it's
an Italian one or its operating in Italy
visible in this photo are three tanks on
the side of the sub one two three and
the middle tank holds the high-pressure
air supply while the other two tanks are
the ballast tanks they hold them take in
the salt water the ballast tanks are
used to change the buoyancy of the sub
to account for changes in the total
weight of passengers from one dive to
the next basically once all the
passengers are on board and the hatches
are closed the pilot will pump water
into or out of the ballast tanks in
order to get neutral buoyancy and then
they use the thrusters to move the
vessel take it beat the surface and also
to bring it back up on the surface
here's another mark three types of being
launched called the looking-glass and
basically on all these submarines is we
require that there always be two matches
one forward one aft particularly for
those carrying more than six passengers
this particular sub has a displacement
of one hundred and six tons there's
another one there's a twenty two acrylic
viewports on the sides of the sub here
and then of course is one that's in the
front so that the pilot can see and also
that the passengers can have a very good
view and the acrylic viewpoints are
designed and fabricated according to an
asme standard the viewports are a
critical critical system they're acrylic
and after a number of cycles you know
they do fatigue so and they also have to
keep very clean and prevent them from
being scratched here's the newest most
revolutionary submersible all the ones
you've seen prior to this one this slide
are basically pressure steel just the
pressure hulls made out of steel and
this one here is called the sea bus and
it's manufactured you focus on its
manufactured and in France by a company
called Comex and basically here you see
the the steel rings and there's a big
large steel part of the hold forward and
also aft and then there's the steel
cylinders down here basically the the
entire structure is is acrylic you don't
see the acrylic yet but this is the
frame by which the acrylic will be
around and the idea of course and you're
in the business of tourists submersibles
you want to have as much viewing area as
possible and this is quite revolutionary
in this design that you can see well
here's the fibreglass deck
while the acrylic you still don't seem I
think there's very large acrylic
cylinders that would be put into this
structure and the battery pods are the
batteries will be put in these
cylindrical pods and the batteries are
used also they can be shifted the weight
can be shifted of the battery in order
to trim the vessel very very I guess
very advanced technology here in
reviewing this design here's where it's
built you can see they're clearly
cylinders again the acrylic cylinders
take pressure loadings but it's very
poor for taking bending loads and all
the bending loads are taken out by the
steel frames bending torsion and those
sort of loads so this is the the newest
technology and in submersibles and I'm
sure if you're a passenger on that one
you get a very good view this particular
vessel carries 50 passengers and cause
something like three and a half million
dollars and it was operated in the
Mediterranean off the coast of Monte
Carlo
here's another submersible this one here
is designed by Jacques Piccard of
Switzerland and this shows the pressure
hole and it's called the SPT 16 it
carries 16 passengers and it's
fabricated by solsa brothers and this
photo shows actually there's you can't
see it but there's any way there's
strain gauges on the pressure hull and
the thing is suspended by its lifting
lugs and this is one of the design
conditions of a submarine is that
journey they're lifted in and out of the
water and that does put quite a bit of
stress on the whole so that's one of the
tests that is going to going yeah
this one here was small enough that well
that's it's hard to see here but you
hear that you have the submarine hoe
here and this is inside of a hyperbaric
chamber our rules require that all
submarines be tested 25% above its rated
depth so this one here was small enough
to be able to put into a pressure
chamber to test it in most cases the
Atlantis submarines the big ones you see
they actually take it drop it down into
the water unmanned and drop it to a Def
that's 25 percent greater than the
operating depth make sure that it
withstands that pressure
basically haven't you shown you how what
the stertorous Emerson was look like and
how they're built I just want to give
you just a brief overview of what a
typical tourist submersible operating
scenario was like first a tourist buys a
ticket and by the way a ticket as I
understand in Hawaii costs about $70 in
other places about 60 so on average it
cost sixty to seventy dollars to take a
ride in one of these and then they go to
a dock area where they board a ferry
boat a transport ferryboat well sorry
that's and they right out to where the
submersible is and they go out to the
dive site and the ferry boat rendevouz
with the tourist sub and it offloads
the let's say forty eight passengers and
also unloads the the 48 that are due for
the next dive and I just show this this
one that's at least on the surface and
the most dangerous part in the operation
of these submersibles is really at the
point where they're doing the at sea
transfer of the passengers that's the
most dangerous point because you have
two moving platforms and anyway from an
operational point of view that's
considered the most dangerous part not
the part that you're in underneath the
water and then what happens is with all
the tourists on board then generally
they get an orange orientation talk
about safety tell people about emergency
exits lifejackets and breathing
equipment then the dive is made let's
say down to about 150 feet and it
follows a standard flight plan usually a
scenic route along the bottom and
generally there will be some sunken
small boats or ships or something that
is very scenic for the people to look at
and journeys maybe a diver will come
down and feed some fish one thing this
is the surfer support
boat this is the Atlantic for the
Atlantis submarine and the dive usually
lasts about 45 to 55 minutes and the
surface boat actually goes above the
submarine at all times because again
when the submarines below the water you
can have some other recreational boat
like a sailboat come over it and just
maybe there's an emergency at the time
and the submarine has a surface so
there's always a boat like this that
really just mimics the motion of the
path of the submarining also keep boats
away yes and also there's there in
continuous radio contact and journey
there might be a scuba diver aboard too
in case there is an emergency basically
during a day they probably made the
vessels make about eight to twelve dives
some opera some even operate at
nighttime because you can put lights
down there I guess professor edgerton's
strobe lights and also get night trips
as well at the end of the day then boat
like this would tow the submarine back
to its base where it's cleaned up and
that batteries are recharged and so on
to date there's been something like a
million and a half passengers that have
taken tour submersible rides and I think
a lot of these companies are hooked up
with cruise ships so that I think as the
cruise ship business has been growing so
is this business because I think
everybody that comes to a port you're on
a cruise ship and if you have an
opportunity to write a submarine like
this you probably would take it so
apparently it's a very very good
business 30 submarines out there and
there's more being built so hopefully if
you ever get a chance I wish I could
take a ride in one thank you
a couple of questions for Donna Lou Oh
about a knot knot or a little bit less
than or not you want to go slow because
you want to you know the people have to
see plus the thrusters aren't their
powerful anyway so a little less than or
not yes sir
yeah usually they have but they had the
ballast tanks on the side and what you
want to do is get neutral buoyancy and
then they generally I think take use of
thrusters to go down and the thrusters
that come back up so they will take on
water basically - I don't think they use
it really for descending or ascending
they use the thrusters for it sir so I
think it's a radio telephone I believe I
believe so yes acoustic telephone
perhaps yeah
that's a good question I really don't
know their it question was what we're
dealing with stand a speargun shot in
terms of the strength of the acrylic I
suppose it could but you are
yeah I thought the Kama was because
there's too many square corners in the
in the openings that they had a high
stress concentration but the ASME
there's a pressure vessel human
occupancy standard for acrylics and
that's what's you have to meet but there
is this I think it's most acrylics are
good for something like 15,000 cycles of
pressure loading so there is a life
limit on these acrylics so that is a
certainly a consideration and also you
don't want to get a lot of scratches on
the acrylics either a lot of stress
concentrations there yes
inside the sub it's just normal
yeah and the assault is also
air-conditioned it's just you just walk
in and it just it's this ambient
pressure yes sir
yeah there is there is again does I they
have to record the number of dives and
and and in order to meet our rules
because they do have to be inspected on
a yearly basis - you have to be taken
taken out well taken out of the water
obviously and to go through a thorough
inspection okay I would like to spend
the last few minutes giving people a
chance to ask any further questions of
any of the speakers in the panel so we
produced the the sails are made of
material which is relatively stretchy
compared to a rigid material like a
composite so we produced full-length
tubular battens
and those of you that watch the
America's Cup we were pleased in that we
were able to reduce a significant amount
of weight out of the battens but also
the Italians in the last race broke
battens and with all the investment in
technology such as Jerry and others some
broken batten containing what does a
broken down and Jerry due to the
aerodynamic predictions of the sails
well I expected it to be terrible but I
noticed that the Italians slowed down
very little when there's broke so the
answer is I don't know that's wrong
that's the wrong answer
anyhow we supplied bill cokes boat
exclusively we didn't work although we
had many of the other boats interested
in our balance they were much lighter
and they were very durable we supplied
their their team exclusively
Wow
yeah the the trick with fibrous material
is to try and have the flexibility in a
manufacturing process to be able to
change fiber orientations and the
advantage as ted indicated as well with
four small tubular structures this
traditional braiding technology produces
a seamless form and there's some
flexibility to change fiber orientations
but by no means is it the only method in
which you can achieve a similar end so
really part of the creativity comes in
with adaptation of manufacturing
technology and textile technology in
particular to get five replacement and
varieties of fiber placements in a
structure so it's not it's not the
essential ingredient but it's just a
means of achieving a certain type of
fiber replacement and certain fiber
orientations well it was a fairly small
contribution and that they were looking
for some hulls that would keep them
afloat and let them get up to speed when
all the design really took off and flew
and instead of having to recreate a hall
we were able to let them use the kayak
haul forms that we had to create just a
light hull so we were hoping we'd find a
reduction in drag with the transom Stern
some would destroy our model test
suggested that we might and we tested a
rowing shell first by taking one of our
models that was just a little bit off
optimum because he wanted to save the
optimum model to make him old from and
we reduced the water we made it ahead
with bulkheads in the stern and reduced
the waterline length five and ten
percent of the length and towed it and
we got a drag reduction a trace space of
in the order of about a percent and we
built a few boats and they seemed to
fare about like any other ones but they
were a little bit more difficult to
avoid bouncing around when you rode in
but basically worked reasonably well and
a few years later we got back to going
to the tell
tank with one of the optimum models that
would done and found that we didn't we
didn't get that drag reduction what
actually had happened was we had picked
a model with a senator buoyancy a little
too far forward from optimum and when we
couldn't put the transom on we had moved
this senator bland C close to optimum in
it I guess it's the changes were so
small it's kind of hard to separate
those things out we tried to do the same
thing with kayaks and they're very
clearly the wetted surface associated
with the transom shape increased the
drag immediately and there was no doubt
about it it seems like possibly if
you're getting up at food not numbers
have won or over which is most of these
shells and kayaks are operating about
point six food number you make you start
to get an opportunity but if the speeds
they're going you don't get much of a
drag reduction in the waves and you
really increase surface area
it's it's really quite accurate in fact
on that the actual mechanics involved if
you're if you're in the aerospace
industry the answer is really no but if
you're working in other applications
where resolution in terms of stiffness
or mechanical properties or thermal
properties you actually they're fairly
good analytical methods based on
mechanics really that allow you to
predict properties quite well strength
on the other hand is very difficult to
predict you can get sort of elastic
properties and you know thermal
properties but strength is one of these
issues which is really plagued the
composite industry and it's all of us
that are sailors are familiar with many
examples of whether it's a mast falling
down or windsurfer mass braking or a
rudder post in the Fastnet race failing
that technology is not really quite as
well developed and that's led to a lot
of caution I think in terms of use of
these in you know applications such as
the aerospace where lives depend on the
performance of the structure so physical
properties yes strength no and that's an
area where there's a lot of academic
work in a place like MIT and other
institutions to try and get a better
handle on the analysis of the failure
modes
I don't know who knows about eels
falling off I I think I'm as far as some
I know my knowledge is limited I know
Jerry do you know more about that boat
well well I do but I'm not in a position
to talk about it okay
there's been lots of talk but the
problem is right now but deed of gift
the last victor has that as the site the
last victory the last victorious Yacht
Club not the individual and that there's
been a lot of acrimony over that because
there are many people right now who feel
that San Diego was one of the worst
places to sail for the America's Cup but
the San Diego Yacht Club doesn't feel
that way and they're there they're the
choice at the moment is theirs and I
would hope that that they would that
there would be some kind of an agreement
soon where the winner has the choice of
venue it will make it a much more
interesting event
the river area and we were breaking
let's say on the average of three masks
a week so we got to get a pretty good
feeling as to what work we do know the
fibers floor mask when a heck of a lot
faster on the racing sail but in terms
of the extreme activity something in the
other spark was a little bit better we
really never got a handle on we
understand you're looking into some of
the techniques that
well you must have had an unusual
serpent's you know unusual testing and
that yeah but I think that what you find
is that because of the nature of the
sport being as extreme as it is that
there are certain conditions that will
break any product and as an example the
mass that we manufacture are used by
like 90% of the World Cup athletes so
what happens is if they're sailing
extreme conditions you find often that
the top athletes will have more failure
with the product that they use most
prevalently but you know we don't think
that there's anything inherently I think
there's certain things when you for
example in that video there's certain
things that people can do as that as a
sport is for guests that put such
demands on the equipment and make it
very difficult for the equipment to
withstand it no matter what the
materials right that's true
well I think you always need to present
a moving target from a product
standpoint and I'm sure Ted can attest
one people and you put a product into
the field the mass that we've had in the
market has essentially been the same for
let's say five years you need to always
present a moving target because what
happens is people will be able to
eventually approach your technology at
least if it's a market that has any
merit at all you'd hope that it's a sign
if people don't do what you're doing
there's some I think there's may be an
indication the market market is maybe
smaller or more narrow than you might
suspect and I'm sure in Ted's case there
were for example opportunities where
people after seeing a product they can
evaluate it and see technically what are
making what's making the product perform
well and then approach that and the
objective is to then take the next step
so you know it's it's sort of a
continuous improvement is really a
nature of manufacturing if you don't
improve eventually someone's going to
produce a better product so I think
that's a very general answer to your
question but if we feel there's a better
product in the marketplace we certainly
you know we you can't just sit back you
have to respond and in terms of me
making the technology given to run over
I think we'll take a couple more
questions and then I'm sure our speakers
will be willing to hang around for a few
minutes to talk to any particularly
ardent seekers so a couple more
questions
well we've been developing those
programs over years and as I indicated
in the talk the key to getting accurate
predictions is the models the models
most of the models that we had before
were upgraded for the America's Cup
program and the sale model developed
with the science sailing dynamometer was
done exclusively for the America's Cup
program one more
I suppose if it was a larger market
would attempt to do that although I
think in many ways it's a little
destructive for an athlete to change
equipment that balance and ability to
perform at your maximum is so sensitive
to any change you make in your equipment
that you wouldn't want a boat that was
dramatically different and if it's at
all possible to incorporate changes in
the design that you don't have to change
equipment that that would be the
preferred approach I'm trying to think
the Pan Am Games in 87 I referred to we
saw a newspaper clipping saying that the
boat had 105 a thousand-meter race by
twenty point three seconds and we say
normally the winning margin is
hundredths of a second maybe at 2/10 of
a second how did it get to be 20 and it
turned out there were extremely strong
tailwind and fairly large waves and the
other boats were burying their boughs
which are generally quite long and
narrow that you can get the paddle quite
close to the centreline whereas most of
the volume of the boat is aft and from
the boat designs I've done in shell so I
had to worry about the pitching of the
boat
I didn't designed a little bit more
volume above the water so it didn't
affect the flat water performance but it
did it enhance the wave performance and
that boat you know just won by such a
huge margin because of the conditions
that that's the type of thing if you can
do it without compromising it's much
better but there are probably some
conditions we didn't want to minimize
your a profile above the water to
crosswinds or something like that that
might be beneficial but particularly in
the canoe which is extremely hard to
control your paddling on one side and
generally if the winds from one side all
the people that paddle on the off side
and do better and it's kind of unfair
that way but there are some changes in
in a larger market you could go after
that this really is an extremely small
market
they're probably just a couple hundred
paddlers that are doing this type of
sport in the country of course rowing is
quite a bit bigger but still in terms of
manufacturing it's not very large well
thank you very much and we should give
our a panel a round of applause and
thank you for coming
[Applause]